hey let's go Ambrose my name it's Peter
Pan the name is PewDiePie welcome back
to another episode of the nightmares
part 2 glad you could make it
it's good to see here again let's keep
playing this game last time I failed it
pretty epically ethically sorry okay um
there's this [ __ ] [ __ ] in here
let's just say hello to him right away
[ __ ] this thing was pretty creepy it's
[ __ ] party legit turning down oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
okay hey hey how you doing buddy you're
looking good you're looking real nice
please don't find me man lifestyle me
way more aggressive
oh no it's not scripted well I suppose
some words scripted let's just take it
nice and easy
alright now it's me now boys nice and
easy wait wait a star an episode
god damn are those baby sleeping on the
bed
no what are you doing climb climb climb
there you go
we're safe I [ __ ] out of my hands so I
was a head fine a same thing [ __ ]
hey boxis [ __ ] you [ __ ] you boxes got
him got him it's really weird you got to
jump and then hold down the mouse button
is kind of what nailed it
[ __ ] that place man ah cheese this game
it's for proper scary man I like it
though I like it do you like leave a
comment right now telling me what are
you wearing
that's right I know I know you're not
wearing pants
disgusting put on some pants I'll shoot
me I give him the stomachache I'm hungry
could that be it like I got a lot of
energy and energy got a lot of energy
good [ __ ] I'm really starving is that
the Baumbach the cafeteria we call it we
call it bottling if you're cool you call
it bum ba if you lame you call it like
it does anyone give a [ __ ] no joke I'm
really starving here okay we'll see if
we can make it there all right come on
Lady can I have a sandwich please
I thank you buddy hey that's so nice
thank you - okay we ate a I hope there
was nothing I hope you didn't do
anything mad with it
you don't seem like the trust where the
kind but thank you thanks I'll give you
a Hillary Clinton thank you jump thank
you
let's go through here we now have the
strength
oh god that's a news that's a news I
hope we don't get to use it I don't hope
we don't get to use the news
I'm sorry I need to stop I can't help
myself I'm in the sewer what is this oh
boy this looking scary boy do you think
we can climb in the background I think
maybe good cool okay
why are we doing this Oh oh [ __ ]
okay we're fun I was hoping we could add
jump
again oh we can okay cool bit weird I
like you I love this game it's
incredible I hope it stays consistent
you know I don't know what the point of
letting these they are but they're lit
so it's all good
why are you watching me got them
okay so we're here now can we climb the
chain perhaps yes we can yes we can
everybody on a roll a lot of flow in the
rhythm of the game and a lot of people
don't like it was almost like games play
themselves but are you [ __ ] idiot
there are deaths okay uh what's that oh
look there was a glitch in the game
where I wake up here that's so strange I
wonder what happened there are deaths
that's for [ __ ] Amy that's for [ __ ]
Abadie real heroes and never die because
that's a reference I don't play
overwatch I'm not a [ __ ] Mary I don't
play games games are for nerds
honestly right you don't play games
either you've watched people play games
that's hardcore
I'm only playing games because I have to
okay
like I would not be playing this game
games over nerds man
that a good monologue but go nailed it
why am I not just editing it out these
beds I kind of like it to flow the game
I don't want to interrupt it you know
what I mean maybe I'll try and cut as
little as I as I can you [ __ ] idiot
oh okay we're fine I wasn't talking to
you I'm talking to me never call you an
idiot unless you did something really
stupid in front of me
Thanks
that's right see if we can do this jump
properly this time
that would be great I'm going to go as
high as possible
well we can't really get high in this
game kid jump ow
why didn't you tell me why didn't you
tell me that was a bad idea
there was a [ __ ] ladder there why
didn't you tell me
aren't you glad you're watching this I
know I know I hate myself too it's okay
[ __ ] how much was the jump here
definitely not like that get some shoes
girl okay we can't move the ladder but
we can climb here so [ __ ] it life's
handing your ladders make lemonade no I
definitely got that quote right okay it
debit Matt I don't know if I could have
it
alright let's try this one yeah hey what
fun for you hey hey oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
what do we do with that oh oh no no no
no no no no come back here come back
here come back here come back and come
back up up up again you ain't going
nowhere son boom
smack aah ass and then now we go party
don't leave without me thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you
excellent feel we did it I don't even
need your help
so judge full okay so judge full and I
don't appreciate it [ __ ] another puzzle
help help me please
come on come on just squeeze it up fine
what about this one
hey that's pretty good
someone please stop stop nope okay we go
alright the puzzle got it
I wonder someone to go out that's okay
not everyone in life wants to go out
some people like going in I'm more of a
I matter of an in person you know what I
mean what kind of dance is that lady
excuse me yeah baby bear did it we did
it
oh oh oh yeah I forgot we have a short
amount of time let's hurry up
Mehmet about that bad at that matter
Babbitt about that but that squeeze
through okay another creepy area push it
I'm up push it all right
why did I do that why did I do this I'm
fine all we're down there okay that's
cool their desk by the way they're a
desk
what's that why are we here we respawn
here all the way down but do I do
but why I ask it doesn't make much sense
but uh disgusting oh it's the [ __ ]
slugs aah aah what I just want to hug me
I can appreciate a good hug you know
what I mean
the eyebrows are moving completely
random okay has nothing to do with what
I just said
you can ignore the ant I have a
condition hi bro oh yeah I bro it I bro
via yeah let me out there they go again
okay last [ __ ] [ __ ] okay let's be
careful here let's be careful it's
you're real careful
the real careful buddy there we go I
think I need to push this back but I'm
not sure B what do you what do you what
you guys make oh we turn up the
electricity ok cool so we were supposed
to jump down see I told you they're dead
yeah
okay which way do I go
got it
it's very much like inside you know with
a list bitter or whatever but I love it
I love this type of game play oh no oh
oh oh yeah we did it Wow oh no no no no
go back come back come back half Sam I
didn't think of that
nope look away look away look away look
away look away look okay all right here
we go that's pretty good yeah no no no
no no should I just go for it I should
have just gone for it
yeah I didn't get a second to hesitate
come on Darryl - Sarah this man you're
gonna understand wake up girl
look up and smell the ashes here we go
oh not this again
come on that's for what I got to do this
again that's not very nice what is that
thing anyway
I wish I could kill with a knife you
know to me you know wait you know
exactly what I mean
well so what I do that to [ __ ] up a
final edit not a problem
easy I was Oh No okay we might have a
problem here breath okay go
yes yes guru there are there told you
what I say what I say what I say that's
right that's right that's right
photographers yeah yeah go get him whoa
we made it - hey same station how about
a how about that I am rendering a video
while I'm playing this having a bit of a
busy day I hope that doesn't cause any
problems with it I don't know anything I
guess
[Music]
be quiet please
don't you I know everyone's judging me
so [ __ ] hard okay better that baby be
better about that scary baby i love you
you love me I want to see you forget
leave again Jimmy you gotta get him
gotta kill him
complexity click adventure I get you one
day more never mind I'll get you another
day oh my god
my god mr. chair could I please have a
minute am I happy you remember me after
Ali's cake
my gosh shut up god damn I don't give a
[ __ ] - but oh that's a big eye isn't it
I don't know if we should press that
button uh hell let's do it anyway
come on she come on chair it's gonna be
good it's gonna be good it's gonna have
a good everybody have a good press the
button oh hi I'm doggie
i'ma lesson like that that's the people
sleeping from before what is happening
here
what can I
can I jump through you guys think I can
jump through maybe you have to move the
chair let's move
No oh we can climb out without the chair
okay miss the chance missed it you of
everything I love you so much
remember the mean the chair mode
accident it was so funny
no it was was cringe which and so with
this potato people I don't really know I
don't really know what to do here let's
try that again
[Music]
is this open
it goes it closes as soon as we look
away this is definitely a puzzle oh we
can change it there's this cat damn
potato oh and there's a ship
chef and there's that place and there's
that all this grandma let's go see
grandma how you're doing grandma no the
door is still closed then one was the
point maybe that's where we need to go
maybe some guidance along the way
good times chair good times
we must be in some weird bus potato
people come back here you shut up a
[ __ ] I'll get ya I'm like it yeah I'm
off the bus buddy okay
I very zoomed out here I don't know why
let's go here let's go here Bryce what
do you say what do you say what do you
say old pal
I don't know why I talk okay here we go
here we go
up up up lady what are you doing I said
up up up up to the top oh this place is
nice very nice hey it's a I know where
we are
no no it's the chef a chef we got a bull
a suitcase I remember I remember
everything
Sam this part is not good the shaft
I think we saw like all their enemies
that are going to come up or this is
different or is it I think we just woke
someone up so cool they really outdid
themselves with this game man I love it
genius it's the fact that you're small
and you can go through all these places
that you normally wouldn't I mean who
would have stuck yeah man
my best friend oh [ __ ] bye
why am I doing this I don't know someone
has an answer for me please let me know
do we need the plunger is that that what
we need by a [ __ ] bye mom you're
supposed to break done my god oh there's
the key I didn't see it cool
oh okay alright alright alright our back
alright okay I rat okay I'll rat nope
okay where do we put the key must be
somewhere on the floor maybe this
briefcase I think I thought breach okay
now you are Union now where do we put
the key
it's too heavy um okay we got to push
the door open
got it cool little puzzle there like it
I like it a lot very nice cut no throw
it throw it buddy you gotta throw it
it's one of those this is like a almost
that gameguardian of Guardium the galaxy
listen I might throw it you've pressed
jump okay Guardian The Last Guardian
yeah just throw that goddamn dog food I
don't think we need this anymore
bye alright open the door singsong Oh
boom hey it's a monkey
I love these cute cute what do we do
with it throw it out the button go oh
it's working
yes alright sorry I can't help you mr.
monkey ah we need to pull these boxes
doesn't look like they're pulling you
know what I mean
you know what I mean you dirty dirty
dirty dick I think I can reach that No
I think you can lend me a monkey hand oh
that's my boy
hey you come with me you're awesome dude
we're a true that's what I'm talking
about
that's why we're gonna finish the whole
game with you buddy
mr. mr. mean get me sick
I'm stuck again
Oh we need him again we need them again
yes go know what I say nope go what go
I got damn yeah boy you're the best mr.
me hell yeah let's do a little dance do
a little dance make a little love
get down night oh yeah look at her leg
you like that you like it yeah that's
right hey hey hey nope
when I told you about your pan damn
weirdo goddamn rear there fine why does
everyone that watch it ie oh no I'm
getting sick something wrong with this
I'm hungry again what that's so strange
I'm not leaving you behind buddy I may
be starving but I'm not living my best
friend behind of anything if anything
happens to you I'll be devastated I'm
quitting this playoff I'm so hungry now
ah why does no one feed me I was think
about that in games when you play
Uncharted which is like the kind of kind
of game that you know it's the same
timeline but you never eat you just
never eat or the last of us or whatever
you never eat you never eat that never
bother anyone else this game you eat
this game is realistic I don't know why
I have to punish myself
mr. musics you're coming with me buddy
ain't leaving you behind for nobody you
saved my life I saved yours
get out of here rats sound sorry mr.
Mitas just gonna have a little snack
have a little snack hopefully don't get
locked in here
Oh God rat food I should do the trick I
[Music]
didn't mr. macey
ah [ __ ] this is bad this is real bad
oh that's creepy those hands
I think you want to touch myself all
right man if it we are the head oh okay
are you waking up
boom bam bam ow I'm fine I'm fine
where's mr. music where we see where I
say okay we gotta grab that thing some
another separate separate separate
events we've gotta grab that thing
father do you why am i singing this song
to some McKenney [ __ ] Sam look a jump
and then grab thank you jump in the
grant jump in the gear boy yeah boy
am I like a little legs dangle okay
let's swing I think that's the trick
here yeah oh all right
oh my game I already figured it out all
right I don't need you go go go go go
whoa
where is he I supposed to me thinks I
need to find him he was my only lover it
was the only one that saw me for what I
really was a selfish [ __ ] I loved him
like it was my own child
jump nailed it nailed it oh hey feels
good that's good man
feels great I love it how you doing
there oh no I forgot we're dealing with
is he blind oh okay well maybe we can
sneak back what are you doing he's
making something he can smell me
no you can smell me no no no no no
listen taking that's so creepy creepy is
the right word for this game man ah
maybe he's just making potatoes wait a
minute
what do I do if you can smell me
all right I'm smell mic nope [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that honest tonight
anyone oh you've done it you've done it
napkin no hawk you can smell me what do
I do if you can smell me
it's not many options if you can smell
you buddy
what do I do
I can't really climb anything okay if
you can smell men's gonna run by alright
I was clearly supposed to go in that
hole a big part I swear he farted there
that's embarrassing for him not for me
what's that their own - thank you
appreciate all the support appreciate
all the support that I'm getting on this
playthrough my zero depth playthrough
really appreciate it
run run run run run run I don't know how
I messed up I literally could have the
run straight forward oh oh god has the
door no okay alright it's a plus we have
time that's a shoe here you're my new
best friend shoe all rights button is in
it no it's not can I climb this no okay
hmm well then oh let a crank Otis oh oh
oh my lovely let's crank it up for us
yeah no I got he's gonna come and you
just tell me by creepy I get goosebumps
I don't know by you guys okay let's do
this we can do this I know we can I know
we can
it's got a pull on through just like
just like other people that produce and
can't figure anywhere no no [ __ ]
I'm going [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
dude it's so hard
god damn that was creepy I don't like
that guy I don't like him
don't want you hey it's a shoe it's a
shoe everyone glad you could make it
shoe oh yeah it end oh wait I saw a
liner I don't know what the point of me
letting this is I'm sure if I was going
to comment and be like you [ __ ] idiot
it's so [ __ ] obvious you lit in the
light to make the soul of the game a lit
and ordered some [ __ ] like that
I don't hey more shoes everyone great to
meet you shoes nice to meet you that was
a this is that this is so cool this part
reminds me a little bit of
Oh God is there something in the shoes
oh god I forgot there's something in the
shoes there's something in the shows go
ah God you can't shoe the shoe master
did you guys no no no no no no
yeah you can't shoe the shoe master
let's RAM the shoe master disaster okay
so now what's the plan Felix well I
guess I just die I don't have a high
that's a box there isn't it I don't see
the point of going there we're just
gonna have to hope
I have a really bad feeling about it
hey I made it oh my god whew that was
close
whew okay we did it we're doing good
we're doing good oh I hate them so much
oh no no run please mr. mee thing No Go
Go
what am I doing here go in there go in
there oh my god is he going up with me
oh he best not find me
you better not find me boy oh god he's
gonna come here next weary oh this thing
is real man
Oh attention retention no open they are
potato people distract him wait a minute
maybe they are whitney on and on oh yeah
I don't like him max what's here oh
sorry that's why I'm saying there's
something hidden
this blanket loose Oh mr. music no hey
we're fine
hi Monday I told you I came back for you
buddy I would never leave you behind
that's right you're coming with me the
whole game I told you the whole oh oh oh
oh oh it would be great if you actually
didn't make noise maybe you use them to
distract him yes that actually makes a
lot of sense where am I
okay
the goal for me to distract him
somewhere perhaps why can I jump up here
for example if I throw the mr. musics
there does that it no I'm sure there's a
way I can go up here I just haven't seen
it maybe here maybe here yeah it's here
No oh my god II cream
okay so we'll just wait for him to be
there then we'll throw a mr. musics
careful now careful mr. meetings I love
you you like you won my champ go
distract him
I'll stick my bag but didn't work that
didn't work let's get the [ __ ] out of
here oh no no go for me what I do know
why did I not throw it farther why did I
not throw it farther god damn you idiot
mr. musics do your job
I just had to climb off stop off don't
know don't touch me I don't like you I
don't like when you touch me
hi go oh no his companions in typical
nailed it there are that what'd I tell
you what'd I tell you
not just an amazing humble person but
also extremely good at games oh no oh no
it never ends does it
never ends does it okay so what do we
got
I always just got through what is what's
the worst thing that can happen oh oh I
made a little oopsie
go go go go go oh no he's here oh [ __ ]
he's distracted by the shoes oh [ __ ]
okay well that could have gone better
what do I do here okay I'm just gonna
get I'm just gonna get grabbed the chute
graduatin ah okay the chute trick didn't
work okay if you didn't see it but here
I am sure throw Oh God
do that again please but do it properly
please she's looking at show so now
please just throw this publish you
please just throw the shoe throw the
show throw this yes yes yes the clocks
are helping my clock up gosh and what's
the clock so low I'm out I'm so out of
here
I'm so done with it haha how are these
books balanced barnum meet tomorrow ok
maybe we can climb here okay we can move
this game gets intense by hey that's the
piano I'm sure nothing bad was going to
happen with that at all
at all hey it's the candle let's let it
let's let it
what kind of shut up oh okay okay oh no
I think you heard it that's some
straight-up parkour stuff I'm a good
climber
I got to hand it to myself oh no oh no
oh no I better stay down here a little
bit down on that love oh oh I don't like
him I don't like as a crank there I see
it you see it too don't you okay let's
be careful here he's sniffing sniffing
like Edgar okay let's careful there's a
crank here somewhere
[Music]
see if we can find it
can't we go through it I'm climbing the
books I didn't realize there's a mr.
musics excellent okay we're fine we got
this bro damn it don't mess up what did
I say
what'd I say let's serve some stuff at
him if you can just run through yep the
answer was yet we need to crank that
okay
please don't come now out of all times
please not now
thank you we did it we did it we did it
we did it awesome awesome oh there it is
okay so are we gonna have to walk all
the way how it's impossible can we even
throw this how would that be possible I
think I know what must be done and I
don't like it we're gonna have to run
it's another one of those we're gonna
have to press the TV he's going to come
in and we're just going to pray for the
Lord and he likes television run run run
run run run no no no no no no no Go Go
Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go
Go Go Go Go Go Go
do you like Go Go I don't like parks oh
my god oh my god oh my god crank that up
dog crank that's so hard
come on come on not again I'm going I
don't even get care I don't even care
but Oh swing swing swing it I don't
think I cranked it enough ah yes yes ah
okay okay I really really really really
really need to end this episode here but
I really love this game so much
please didn't like being going I don't
see the brooch in the next episode thank
you for always loving support they are